no one wants to read a feminist reading
of anything no one cares people just
want to watch the [__] play there are
some people who deserve to be rounded up
and put in a camp all right and it's
these people yeah
Shakespeare's Club put some misogyny and
racism warning on a midsummer night yes
yes we want to know that any play that
we watch may contain things that we
don't like yeah absolutely lovers of
Shakespeare are questioning if they are
awake or are dreaming after the Globe
Theater placed a Content warning On A
Midsummer's Night A Midsummer Night's
Dream should one of Shakespeare's most
innocuous place it is one of his
comedies yeah he was a massive racist
man yeah he probably was mate he was
living about how long ago now about over
500 years ago yeah so what mate well
deep I mean behind the Anton what an
outrageous comment from Francis yeah I
mean outrageous what he was living 500
years ago so what's your point what he
he wasn't supposed to know that the
Norms of society are going to change 500
years he's a [__] genius mate what do
you mean so you should have known he
should have been able to look into the
future exactly and predict what's
happening he should have seen the future
I mean you are you a genius or what yeah
are you talented are you the creator of
some of the greatest works of you know
dramaturgy or whatever the English word
for that is in the history of humanity
right if you knew that why didn't you
know that 500 years later the normal
society would change and a pink head
Minge at a university would get
triggered by the fact that there's some
misogyny in Midnight Midsummer Night's
Dream no I'm completely agree with you
and if Shakespeare if you'd spent less
time sitting on your ass writing things
like should I compare big to his
summer's day they aren't more lovely and
more temperate if you'd actually spend
more of the time training your brain to
see into the future sure yeah maybe this
kind of nonsense wouldn't have happened
and anyway did you not have unconscious
bias training in your day mate yeah if
you didn't why not why don't you seek it
out and if it wasn't available why
didn't you start it mate it wasn't
available he's from the Midlands they
still don't have unconscious bars
shining up there at the moment they're
mostly unconscious that's why exactly
Mike from all that boost and from the
fact that they live in the Midlands yeah
anyway let's read this article because
it is brilliant uh ticket buyers on the
globe website are told that it contains
language of violence sexual references
misogyny and racism anyway
I mean everything's racist now so why
not anyone with further concerns is
asked to contact the ticketing team
hopefully so they can get [__] thrown
off a bridge
the comedy follows four young lovers who
find themselves in an enchanted forest
inhabited by fairies it's due to run at
the globe until August the 12th
feminist readings of a mid-summer night
stream May focus on the character of
hermia one wants to read a feminist
reading of anything no one cares people
just want to watch the [__] play
apart from the feminists who doesn't
yeah no one cares that like I said
there's about three of them no there's
even feminists don't care about feminist
readings at play because that's like old
school feminist all they care about now
is trans yeah that's all they care about
am I wrong no that is no go on the mum's
net feminist Forum as I know as I do
sometimes as a guilty pleasure do you
every single [__] topic is about
trans I mean they [__] love you yeah
they don't give a [__] about rewriting
history anymore no injecting women into
places they don't belong belong like
offices in other workplaces yeah not
places of power exactly I mean obviously
don't belong there why are you shoving
them in there exactly you know what no
no answer don't don't don't show my full
face I feel bad all those jokes might
get taken seriously yeah oh yeah so look
I completely agree with you women ruin
things and uh let's see what I didn't
say that yeah I mean obviously they do
but I didn't say it yeah I know you
didn't but sometimes I did mean it
sometimes you just need to make it clear
for them otherwise it can't you know
crack through the old skull anyway
uh okay this is I think this is the sort
of thing they're talking about when
they're trying to crack down an online
hey really just me and you joking really
well yeah I'm are we joking are we
making uh very considered points and
then what you know because if we're
going to improve Society we need to do
something drastic I mean let's be honest
mate most of the global population would
agree with us yeah exactly and we know
that the global South are morally
virtuous people unlike us evil Northern
girls right so they know and they know
women should be belong in the home do
you know who those things women should
belong in the home it's Grand anyway
foreign
the jokes guys yeah anyway we've only
got one slot left with them so it
doesn't matter anyway so who is pursued
with hermia who's pursued relentlessly
by Demetrius even though she she knows
she even though she shows no interest in
him and is in love with Lysander yeah
what a rapist exactly Demetrius is
helped in his uh Endeavors by Jesus I
mean his father who demands she marries
Demetrius if she refuses she face being
sentenced to death or banished to
another this is how it should be yeah
exactly elsewhere in the play Oberon
King of the fairies I mean that's
problematic isn't it you can't call them
that man and look him he's using drugs
for sex as well
I mean not stereotyping yeah it is I
mean this is a nightmare for lgbtqi plus
Mike you can't have Oberon just
wandering around behaving a feminate and
telling poppers I mean King of the
fairies you can't call him that no it's
it's 20 23. I mean it wasn't when he
wrote it it was like 19 not 19. 1453 or
whatever ever was right but still you
can't say king of the fair you can't
call him King of the fairies yeah he's
queer he's queer exactly and gender
non-binary drugs his spouse yeah right
Titania to make her fall in love against
her will with the next thing she sees
this happens to be bottom a character
with the head you've got a character
called bottom yeah who who is
interacting with the king of the fairies
oh [__] help I mean that there is a
lot of a lot of prejudice in this right
yeah there is why didn't they do a
warning about homophobia exactly I'm
sure there's about six gay people all
crying and that's just the members of
the course anyway the word ethiop a
racist term from someone from Ethiopia
what exactly was it racist in his day
probably was mate I mean let's be fair
if he's anyone's going to be racist it
was that lot yeah for me Ethiopia all
sub-Saharan Africa uh appears in
egg-free scene too where he's used by
Lysander to refer to hermia it's also um
it's also reference in Romeo and Juliet
when Shakespeare rod the play in 1590 It
is believed upper-class people pride of
themselves on the likeness of their skin
because it indicated they did not work
outside like many plebs yeah the globe
and the Cambridge University press
stream uh free seminars under the name
of anti-racist Shakespeare good to
examine his works with a focus on social
justice that's what we need [__] me that
is what we need for too long we have
been seeing works of King Lear and it's
not been done through the lens of social
justice Francis you know what I mean I
know this will sound controversial it
may do but I think Hitler was right well
there are some people who deserve to be
rounded up and putting Camp all right
and it's these people yeah feminists
it's not feminist mate feministers who
watch the show because we bang on about
it oh yeah that's true so feminist I
mean they don't watch it anymore not
after this mate no they love it anyway
let's carry on with this yeah so let's
keep reading the article uh an episode
on a midsummer night stream was filmed
in 2021 Professor Vanessa Cordero fought
me because Latina so she's obviously
loves banging on who chose English at
Andrews University in Michigan said in
the seminar
it's funny and literally a spectacular
play but that spectacle can do a lot of
work to gloss over the problematic
gender and racialize Dynamics in this
play One Direction was the last time she
got laid mate
probably about the time that Shakespeare
wrote it right uh in the gloves
production of The Merchant of Venice
last year ticket buyers were warned
about scenes of anti-Semitism what is
wrong with you retards
and bullying the warning also mentioned
colorism and racism strong language and
scenes of a sexual nature the whole of
course there's scenes of anti-Semitism
in a Merchant of Venice
it's it's not watching that that film
Amistad
although 12 Years a Slave and going yeah
there's uh there's going to be some
scenes of slavery in here mate yeah just
to watch out watch out
and also there's some racism in there as
well so what do you reckon yeah I reckon
should we cancel Shakespeare yeah let's
cancel them he's just trying white CIS
man I mean he probably wasn't actually
really yeah I mean there are some there
is a theory that he may have been a
woman just like God really yeah
[Music]
do you see why we have to move Raw on to
locals do you see now no they don't they
don't go